bitte schön danke schön ein Geschenk von
Hamza welch eine Seltenheit [Musik] hallo
ihr Lieben willkommen zu einem neuen Video
bei dem ich ein Starbucks Rezept Nachmache
weil der Carrot Cake so gut bei euch ankam
hat haben sie mir direkt den nächsten Kuchen
geholt drei Jahre her ne ja super aber wir
nehmen wieder Fahrt auf und ich gucke jetzt
noch was haben sie mitgebracht hat und was
ich heute nachmachen darf oh das ist der chocolate
cake das ist dieser unfassbar schokoladige
Kuchen der immer in super schmales Stückchen
geschnitten ist kann das auch annehmen ja
das sind schon immer so so unfassbar schmale
Stückchen muss ich echt sagen ich wollte
gerade sagen gerade ähm also wenn man den
zu Hause selber macht kann man hier natürlich
auch in breitere Stücke schneiden es kann
auch sein dass es so Schokolade und süß
ist das ähm ja einfach so ein schmale Stück
dann total angebracht ist es besteht aus ähm
zwei saftigen schokoböden und obendrüber
ist auch noch mal Schoko Boden quasi als Hügel
drauf gegeben ich finde das eine Optik mega
hübsch nebenbei bemerkt und Schokoladen Arsch
da gehe ich jetzt mal Türen dann machen wir
gleich weiter das war eine home one so ich
habe mir Gedanken gemacht und eigentlich total
blöd weil der Kuchen besteht ja aus zwei
saftigen schokoböden plus noch mal diese
dicke Bodenschicht oben drüber die einfach
auch die Optik macht das ist ja dann quasi
wie eine dritte Schicht also habe ich jetzt
zwei Tortenringe plus noch einen dritten für
diese Schokostückchen ist total blöd vor
allem abgesehen davon weiß ich nicht ob ihr
jetzt wirklich drei Tortenringe zu Hause habt
das heißt ihr backt viele macht das natürlich
Sinn dann erst kam ich auf die Idee Moment
bin ich da nicht vorher drauf gekommen ich
mache das ganze in einer in einem Backrahmen
also eckig und steche dann die runden Böden
aus und werde dann aus dem Rest der ja dann
entsteht weil wir Runde Böden hier ausstechen
daraus mache ich dann die wie heiße gar nichts
mehr ich check gar nichts mehr ich bin noch
zum Film jetzt hier essen also ihr habt bestimmt
verstanden was ich meine weil die Kiki Unity
die Backe auch sehr gerne
also ich finde es war wirklich spaß beiseite
aber so ein Backrahmen macht eigentlich immer
Sinn ich habe jetzt hier auch ähm unten drunter
mein gelochtes Blech also das ist schön gerade
ist und ich auch nicht so mal Stellen habt
ihr total durchgebacken und trocken sind und
dann wieder umstellen habe die zu feucht sind
und bei so einem bei so einer Geraden Unterlage
habt ihr eben den Vorteil dass alles gleichmäßig
durchgebacken ist ich habe jetzt schon mal
alle Zutaten für meinen saftigen Schokoladen
zurechtgelegt und abgewogen und meine hassaufgabe
ist eigentlich immer Kuvertüre zu hacken
ich hasse das also das würde ich das will
ich am liebsten immer abgeben oder ich sollte
einfach Schokodrops benutzen in Zukunft aber
sobald ihr das fein gehackt habt könnt ihr
das schon mal zusammen mit Butter und es muss
viel Butter sein weil das wird ja ein saftiger
Schokokuchen kommt das zusammen mit Butter
hier einmal in den Topf und da dann den Herd
jetzt nicht auf volle Pulle schalten weil
sonst verbrennt euch die Butter und dann habt
ihr einfach nur ja verbrannte Butter dann
müsste alles nochmal neu machen sondern auf
niedriger Stufe alles zusammen schmelzen lassen
und sobald es geschmolzen ist noch mal 15
Minuten abkühlen lassen und dann können
wir erst Eier mit dazu geben weil sonst habt
ihr Rührei und das möchten wir jetzt nicht
im Kuchen [Musik] so Zucker kommt jetzt zu
den Eiern da könnt ihr auch schon Vanilleextrakt
dazugeben ich mag es einfach das vorab zu
verrühren damit es sich einfach perfekt verbindet
und die Eigelbe schon mal so ein bisschen
homogener werden muss jetzt aber nicht so
ordentlich sein aber das kommt jetzt sowieso
hier rein das ist jetzt schön abgekühlt
also wenn ich fühle es ist noch ein ganz
ganz ganz leicht lauwarm das ist okay und
jetzt einmal mit dem Schneebesen die ganze
Zeit rühren und die Eier Zuckermasse dazugeben
und sobald sich das auch verbunden hat kommen
die restlichen Zutaten dazu das sind jetzt
eigentlich nur noch was haben wir noch schönes
Mehl Backkakao und Backpulver erschrecklich
wenn ihr die Zutaten seht es ist sehr sehr
wenig Mehl aber das bewegt eben dass der Teig
so saftig wird daher traut euch ruhig und
das ganze gebe ich jetzt aber auch noch durch
einen Sieb als er in die klümchen drin sind
oder so gehe ich das dann einfach damit [Musik]
tada der Kuchen ist fertig gebacken und ich
zeige euch jetzt mal was wir müssen nämlich
die Stäbchenprobe machen und dann nehme ich
meinen Schaschlikspieße die braucht jetzt
kein teures Tool dafür ich nehme sogar ein
Schaschlikspieße immer wieder sauber mache
und dann öfter mal verwende so und jetzt
seht ihr dass das also es ist kein feuchter
klebriger Teig mit dran und dann ist er wirklich
perfekt durchgebacken
ja ja ja ja und das lassen wir jetzt zugede
ckt bestimmt nicht auskühlen und in der Zwischenzeit
machen wir die Ganache für die Ganache habe
ich hier Vollmilch und Zartbitterkuvertüre
einmal rein damit dann habe ich hier auf dem
Herd schon mal Sahne
wie du das reingetan hast diese beiden Sorten
Schokolade ist immer da kommt jetzt einmal
zur Sahne Glukose Sirup keine Sorge wenn ihr
keinen Glukosesirup da habt dann braucht ihr
das auch nicht rein und aber es macht die
Ganache einfach noch mal von der Konsistenz
her bisschen geschmeidiger ich schreibe euch
übrigens alle ganz genau Mengenangaben unten
in die Infobox Part Salz habe ich auch noch
weil eine Prise Salz hebt noch mal den Geschmack
genau und jetzt wird die Sahne einmal erwärmt
ihr merkt das dann auch daran dass es so ganz
kleine Bläschen entstehen nicht hoch kochen
also sollte jetzt nicht blubbern sondern wirklich
einfach nur erwärmen und dann gießt ihr
das auf die Schokolade macht den Deckel drauf
wartet fünf Minuten weil das dann schon so
ein bisschen anschmelzen kann und anschließen
wir das komplett einmal durchgerührt damit
so eine richtig schöne schok omasse entsteht
die muss dann halt allerdings Auskühlen daher
habt ihr dann so ein bisschen Entspannung
und können in der Zwischenzeit die Küche
aufräumen und euer Partner kann euch dabei
helfen immer
[Musik]
die Ganache hatte ich jetzt bei mir im Tiefkühlfach
ihr habt ja gerade gesehen dass sie sehr flüssig
war und ihr fester sie wird umso cremiger
wird sie auch also sie ist eigentlich von
der Konsistenz her ja wie unsere cream würde
ich fast schon sagen also wie ein Aufstrich
und das könnt ihr nur also die Konsistenz
könnt ihr nur bekommen wenn ihr es wirklich
kühlt und nicht jetzt auf Zimmertemperatur
stehen lassen ich persönlich habe ja wie
gesagt Platz im Gefrierschrank gemacht damit
es schneller geht das hat jetzt ungefähr
45 Minuten gedauert wenn ihr Zeit habt könnt
ihr das auch einfach in den Kühlschrank stellen
und immer wieder zwischendurch umrühren und
hier ist unser saftiger Schoko Boden den werden
wir jetzt ausstechen dafür werde ich jetzt
erstmal den Backrahmen entfernen damit ich
mir die Ränder jetzt nicht wegreise einmal
mit dem backformlöser rangehen und dann stellt
sich mir das einfach auf so eine eckige Tortenplatte
dann könnt ihr dann wie gesagt einfach mit
dem Tortenring oder mit irgendeinem runden
utensilbermann Tortenring eignet sich das
schon echt am besten einfach die Böden ausstechen
die sind jetzt auch von der Höhe her müssen
mal gucken ich sehe hier an der Skala das
ist ca 2,5 cm oder fast drei ja die Höhe
ist perfekt sehr schön ich liebe es wenn
der Plan aufgeht so dann einmal hier runter
nehmen am besten schiebt ihr das auch schon
direkt vom Backpapier runter dann habt ihr
das lästige Backpapier nicht mehr da aber
ist das erstmal so runter
das kommt weg so und jetzt einmal vom Backpapier
runterziehen dann geht ihr mit dem cakeboard
einfach ganz vorsichtig runter schiebt das
einmal nach vorne zack fertig ich stelle jetzt
einmal können auch vorher markieren dass
sie auch ganz sicher 2 Runde Böden erhalten
ja das kommt hin habe ich auf 20 cm eingestellt
stechen ja auch und den Rest könnt ihr euch
dann gleich zurechtschneiden für die dritte
Schicht quasi so wenn es dann stapeln geht
könnt ihr euch quasi aussuchen nehmt jetzt
ein Tortenring das ist schön gerade ist oder
stapelt ihr das einfach so frei nach Schnauze
ich zeige euch das jetzt einfach mal ohne
Tortenringe beleidigt fühlen bitte also ich
fand das ist echt so damit äh ohne Tore damit
ihr sehen könnt ähm wie viel Creme da jetzt
also danach ungefähr drauf kommt immer mal
wieder rühren ich merke auch gerade dass
durch die restkälte das immer fester wird
und wenn ihr rührt könnt ihr das umgehen
und das wird schön geschmeidig so und bei
Starbucks muss ich sagen sind die Ganache
Schichten wir sind jetzt nicht gerade dünn
oder es geht ne also Mittelding finde ich
also ich glaube jeder der Schokolade liebt
wird auch diese Torte lieben das ist ja echt
schokoporner wie oft habe ich schon gefragt
kannst du bitte das Rezept nachmachen bist
du dann einfach dahin gegangen bist
so eine coppen diese Torte kaufen
die letzten Jahren die einfach nachmachen
noch einmal kaufen auseinandernehmen und speziell
ja sicher man geht auf mein Nacken so ich
denke so ist echt okay oder ein bisschen mehr
so im Anschnitt ja auch schon ne das sollte
ja auch identisch aussehen so und da kommt
jetzt einfach der nächste Boden oben drauf
dann noch mal die gleiche Menge an Ganache
und dann bröseln wir diese Kuchenstücke
noch dazu ja nicht bröseln sondern wir schneiden
sie zu großen Rauten oder Viereck oder sowas
und dann ist es auch schon fast fertig das
Rezept
[Musik]
meine Torte weiß noch 10 Minuten lang im
Tiefkühler wenn ihr kein Platz im Tiefkühler
habt dann bitte noch mal für 30 Minuten in
den Kühlschrank stellen ich habe die Ganache
über dem Wasserbad die ganz kurz erwärmt
dass dort nur wenige Sekunden und dann ist
sie wieder so dickflüssig und das wird jetzt
einmal komplett auf die Torte gegossen ich
habe außen herum überall noch backpapierschutz
gemacht mit der Hoffnung dass ich die Küche
nicht so ein sauer und jetzt kommt es das
freie Moment
oh Gott oh es ist echt das ist wie auch so
Werbung also verboten verboten lecker sieht
das aus und sieht heftig aus jetzt würde
ich aber instinktiv so ein paar Mal klopfen
weil ich will ja dass man die Kuchenstücke
oben auch erkennt und das erinnert mich ein
bisschen Sebastian also ein bisschen Aggression
raus genau und man merkt auch wenn man klopft
guck mal dann sieht man diese schönen Brocken
das macht jetzt so lange bis ihr sie wirklich
vollständig seht und dann den Rand einfach
nur noch glatt streichen dann müsste sie
gekühlt werden fertig
[Musik]
alles gut es ist in Ordnung ich weiß ich
habe letzte Sequenz den Ton verkackt als das
meine Schuld aber aber ein altes Ritual gesagt
immer wenn der Ton scheiße ist
geht das Video immer ganz gut steil ja so
dann wollen wir mal probieren in jede Schicht
einmal haben wir ne vor mir boah das hätte
ich an meinen Nahaufnahme zeigen dass man
gleitet so gut durch mit der Gabel ich kann
es jetzt zeigen
der schmeckt ultra schokoladig also ich sag
ich sag mal so ich bin voll der Schokofan
und daher liebe ich diesen Kuchen ja arbeite
ich mit der frischer
und das ist so eine Mischung aus Herz und
süß also es ist nicht nur ihr weiß nicht
nur auf Zucker Zucker Zucker sondern dadurch
dass wir Zartbitterschokolade haben ist es
auch noch so herb also richtig angenehm richtig
schokoladig einfach immer leckerer als normal
dann müssen wir auch sauber ist nicht schlecht
reden
und mega Schokolade
machen unbedingt unbedingt
so
24 Stückchen oder so rechnen weil die ja
dann auch so ne das ist eine doppelte dreifache
Portion aber es schmeckt echt heftig also
wirklich ich weiß nicht ob einer der oder
sogar der leckerste Schokokuchen ist den ich
überhaupt je gemacht habe auf meinem Kanal
also das ist mega krass hammermäßig sehr
lecker also Leute abonnieren liken like mal
das Video auch wenn ihr jetzt sieht wirklich
liken ne ich gucke jetzt einfach weiter und
gucke das nächste Video nein like das Video
jetzt dort meine Sekunde und es hilft unserem
Kanal echt sehr weiterhin Rezepte machen genau
und dann ja sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten
Mal
[Musik]